okay I can took place like Obama ah and
we're playing extra strain transmissions
will we get the travel to the x2
transmitter antenna array okay and like
always we got a boy kanye west right
here he's happy to be here he's just
happy to be invited you know that guys
let's do this okay okay now let's just
see what the [ __ ] but where my [ __ ]
guns oh I don't know anything equipped I
just started this shot and I can't
cyberdog yeah
how does it work okay we have to go to
the big empty patches a big empty yeah
there we go how's a little dark in here
okay and then look just like random and
we thought here Oh beautiful the big
empty house that that should he see that
I just saw something oh I'll just comes
across on good it's just growling I
can't ok got got got good Wow okay I
gotta go down there and face on like a
man hey cancel
[ __ ] they're just use some so much
ammo yeah quick reload oh [ __ ] you go I
got chef etch stop running Hey look yeah
okay let me search this shirt oh they
all have like they all have shotguns
okay that's right that's say yeah let's
say here I can't baby okay so that's the
big antenna i right i think right where
is it flown that it do enemies keep
responding i don't know so many so many
answers that I have oh it's growling
it's growling it's like hey likes are
like closer okay yeah [ __ ] yeah they
pay something oh [ __ ] that dog thing
like scares make your fingers like a tag
dog on me okay okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
okay okay let's get back to this okay
what the [ __ ] who the [ __ ] is shooting
me now oh now chef those me for a second
okay I don't I just an NGO up in a no
[ __ ] now let's just get to the top I
liked one them I'd like restores your
health though like like I should I got
no [ __ ] hell
does it Jen nice not just [ __ ] dad
okay okay this is a good gun I just
think you have to be so closed off
because my hell [ __ ] sucks is this an
energy weapon I can't [ __ ] tell think
it is right now Chiefs like a regular
gun chef text someone what the [ __ ] that
okay ma'am Wow holy [ __ ] it's like
[ __ ] Leatherface ah
ok looks like I need some [ __ ] ate
this area clear all right Ally
proceeding with sorrow all right Jeff
you do I'll take that damn you should
put some [ __ ] I have oh no wonder
gray
I thought I just picked up something and
I can take a Scot okay um can you shoot
fine don't know what the [ __ ] is going
on scanning hostels
I got your badge put down your weapons
and submit to it on yet another one
where's fuchsia Oh tight fall
yeah buddy base Oh babies yeah yeah yeah
yeah I love talking about chicken and
check and waffles maybe yeah yeah yeah I
don't need sex okay I don't smoke suck
it is for losers empty said ah I guess
that ok scrap metal knob thank you
anything good I got I don't need this ok
so let's continue here let's go Chet get
these stem facts [ __ ] i meani forceps
for my doing a gynecological exam no I'm
not okay I'm not so not gonna take them
take this I KHS I got a drug
that good stuff
it's kinda hard because you stop every
two seconds to like check because every
[ __ ] thing like give you a file
cabinet filled with ammo so we're okay
anyway it's going up right here
Oh felt like a see it's not talking
about there's like [ __ ] all this [ __ ]
everywhere
and [ __ ] desk out money like NIJ
sounds I'm gonna need all this ammo I
bet yeah this is the most exciting about
me and I like it yeah yeah my other 10
yeah like my best friends okay like we
deviate Courtney take out there like so
worked up okay [ __ ] my [ __ ] over
encumbered yeah I got it right kidding
me ya got any way yeah
head
I don't feel like dirty water and I need
got gummy oh you madam for the boxing
ties there we go okay I gotta go out my
bad wait zeca and where else oh no
Georgia the big empty
I say [ __ ] enemy
oh it's like far far it out I see him
yeah
thank you i do I
[ __ ] is that you know finance club board